let's head to New York where Carly
Steele was hanging with the Suicide
Squad crew Will Smith and tattoo happy
margot robbie were all on the red carpet
for the high-energy premiere
what if Jada think of your Walter White
breaking bad luck with the beard and the
both she appreciate it I wanted to bring
the outfit home
it just takes 45 minutes to get off so
by that time you got to lose the MU
Suicide Squad came to play and dressed
to kill will and Scott Eastwood suited
up Jared Leto in Gucci Cara Delevingne
in a $3,000 study dress with cutouts and
boots but it was Margo who wins best
look see how badass you really are are
you ready all right if you could lock
off any cast member in the film and
torture them who would it be well I
think secretly Margot Robbie is it true
you shaped your entire body for this
role I may or may not have the Joker is
in a very hairy character last time you
went commando oh wait a minute
Oh probably like two days ago or
something look it's good to be a bad guy
film is set to open big this weekend but
big Willie's kids already gave him a
review that could be a game-changer
they said this is it I'll never make
anything better than this Deadshot is
the best character I will ever play and
I don't need to stop making movies good
try kids ain't no way will is quitting
acting
you